and we'll close it out with this uh king
interesting
what's up brandon uh this is chris here
from des moines i got a king understand
it for you
breathalyzers i don't drink anymore i've
been sober for quite a while now but
that wasn't always the case so
long story short they gave your boy one
of these because they got one too many
dui's
yup by that i mean four
[Laughter]
threesomes hit this button when you want
to go the supermarket it takes five
minutes to
get ice cream maybe
offered to drive on a first date
those things still don't stop you though
because you have your buddy blowing to
it
or your child wow really
damn it'll go heavy too yeah sometimes
i'll get lucky
and it'll go off while i'm sitting at a
drive-through window or
maybe i'm sitting in traffic i'll be
blown into it oh yeah they randomly
looked over make eye contact
and they're not cheap either um but
anyways king are stinging
breathalyzers gang gang buzz buzz listen
man
what do you say b they're safe you know
you've got a drinking problem
listen you get one of those after
usually your second or third time
i know from experience i've never had it
myself but i had a
a close friend that had to do it i had
to blow into it okay did you yeah i did
do we know him or not nope you don't
know her
but uh it was a problem man
really and they're expensive too they're
expensive
now but they but they passed a rule
because three strikes and you're out
in denver three strikes if you get three
duis you go to you go to prison
three strikes you're out oh wow damn
nick what's up nick did you
my uh sister because drinking's huge in
wisconsin her and her husband got one
for parties
it's a little party favor and everybody
passes around and see who can get the
high score
also a good way to get corona it comes
with uh
separate uh sticks for everybody oh
that's to test your alcohol
level oh yeah you know what you know
what you can't play anymore i was
thinking about this last night for
whatever reason like midnight you know
you can't play anymore cause the corona
no more beer pong oh yeah no more beer
pong
talk about a corona spreader but no one
throw the ball and then your hands drink
it they throw it back
everybody's around i think they've been
playing it differently because now they
just put water in it yeah and they just
hold their
their beers and they take us they'll
take a drink yeah y'all gay
people they were a little ahead of the
corona curve like yeah
we could still play we had the
grassroots version where yeah you played
like and it was just nasty
in a barn we did yeah that's gross y'all
ever done uh edward 40 hands that was my
game oh
i love that game my hands would go numb
would be yeah
but then it was dangerous because you
had you had glass bottles tied to your
hands your hands no it was great
it was one of my favorite games i did it
with mickey's oh yeah those are good man
gangster doug
well this fella i'm saying look if you i
think it's just crazy how
how like you know there's
everything you do it's like we just the
rules keep it getting bent out so that
we could just keep doing it more you can
get three dui's you know
that's a lot man it's a lot i mean after
two you're [ __ ] you got one of those
yeah i think they should have something
almost a little bit more
where if you want to get your car to
start you need to stand on top of your
car and do like two games of ddr
you know that's fair like two just
something that shows a little bit more
that has a little bit more of a social
ramification you know what i'm saying
you run a mile outdoor
under 10 minutes yeah you got to go run
them out do something good for yourself
so then it'll leave you to uh
oh there you go there i am right there
here's somebody right here who obviously
has a drug alcohol problem that was me
in uh college
oh there you go yeah edward 40 here too
much table i know what is that that's
too much
uh 40s or 10. what's what's around
that's what it's athletics
looks like you're getting too much tape
looks like you're carrying two beehives
yeah bro it looks like you're making
molotov cocktails bro like you're the
[ __ ] kimbo slice of [ __ ] ice cream
that's how you do this you look like
wesley snipes and white men can't jump
i do you look like wesley wipes dude
[ __ ] toilet paper in your hands no
that's how i do it get that bud ice
you you you had a real problem huh yeah
yeah yeah would you get all hammered
you're like backflips and [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah doing
cartwheels naked am i right
cartwheels
breathalyzer before you're allowed to do
cartwheels after you've been drinking i
think no i could yeah
i had it like like it's one of those
things it's like i don't know it's like
riding a bike you just
when did you know you hit rock bottom oh
nick sneaking another picture of him in
here
there's nick at the library
and that's the nine-year-old girl yeah
yeah
he's old enough there's a library
reunion
thanks nick but when did you know you
hit rock bottom chappelle
uh i mean not to get all emotional after
my brother died oh wow
you know you got a drinking problem oh
man yeah were you drinking it where were
you drinking mostly
i loved wild turkey oh wow yeah that was
my choice that's that gasolina
i know that's what everyone says every
time i drink that gasoline like what are
you doing you'd finish a bottle
uh you know i you know i actually i
would just go get it at the bars i would
go sit at a like
like i would go to a bar and i would sit
at a i was the guy that was sitting in
the stool
and just [ __ ] drinking are you rich
rich yeah you rich rich doing on the bar
i know i spend a lot of my money at a
bar a lot
well here's my uh we're just shooting
the [ __ ] there
yeah what are you doing there uh i used
to go to this bar back home called
there's a couple of ones bikini lounge
and the other one's called
crescent crescent ballroom and the
crescent ballroom
they used to play that what's that lady
that uh older ladies about that kid rock
song it's kind of slow
no the lady they said something no
they have it on their on the tv it's a
lady that talks about sex she's old
johansson oh yeah yeah uh dr ruth
dr ruth doctor that lady they would they
would play that and i'd just sit there
and
and just drink by themselves by myself
no no company huh no i didn't need
nobody
what do i need yeah who do you need
buddy
got dr ruth yeah i love dwight now would
you mix the
liquor with some pills or you're
drinking but you don't need no i was i
was strictly
everything everything scares me would
scare me but alcohol
yeah there's dr ruth's still alive or
she's still dtf
dude she's dying she no she didn't she
did yeah i'm pretty sure she's really
old back there
did not die yeah 100 she's four seven go
look
born only is she yeah she's 92.92 you
she's not dead
wow she got so much information on sex
that's probably why she's still alive
exactly but has she been doing sex you
think so
oh yeah do you guys remember her who dr
joe hansen she was on tv late night too
i i i learned more from her than dr ruby
i remember sue i remember that doctor
first of all
i learned more nixon what kind of guy
works at a library and goes to learn
from a seven-year-old woman on
television at night she taught me the
come hither motion
gosh you know what i'm mad is that too
[Music]
much
[Music]
i